[Music]
all right let's go out to Chattanooga
and talk to Ethan what's up
Ethan hey Dr deloney thanks so much of
course man what's up so um I a school
teacher um and my wife and I have been
following the baby steps um since the
beginning of this last summer um my wife
and I have been working really really
hard um trying to push trying to find
extra ways to gain income and um we're
able to put about $2,000 a month um
towards our Deb we've got about $25,000
left in our debt awesome hey um real
quick real quick Ethan let me tell
everybody so if you're listening to this
and you don't know what he's talking
about with baby steps um my friend Dave
Ramsey has a program called Financial
Peace University where he has been
helping people get out of debt millions
and millions and millions of people get
out of debt for for three decades now
for 30 years plus and so Ethan you and
your wife are working to get out of debt
right to be to become free financially
free and yall work in that program and
y'all figure out a way on a teacher
salary and whatever your wife does to
have an extra 2,000 bucks a month yall
aren't going to restaurants yall aren't
going um out on fancy dates you're not
going on vacations you're just trying to
pay all this stuff off right yes sir
that is correct pretty amazing that's
awesome okay well thank you um well my
my grandmother who's been like a mother
figure to me uh my my entire life I I I
come unfortunately from kind of A
Dysfunctional Family background um has
offered to let us come in with her
temporarily to help get us out of debt
she wants us to be able to to double the
amount of money we can throw each month
at our debt and um I have been
struggling really really hard my wife is
100% supportive she is entirely behind
me and behind the idea of us moving she
loves my grandmother to death um but I
am struggling greatly with anxiety uh in
regards to this and I'm extremely
bothered by it because this is my
grandmother the closest person that I am
to other than my wife and I'm not sure
where it's stemming from I am very
afraid to move out of my home we rent a
house it's it's not even ours but um
I've lived there for the last three and
a half years my wife and I when we got
married nearly two years ago
she moved into the house with me and
just since I've moved out of my mother's
nine or 10 years ago I've finally had a
stable life and been on my own and I'm
just extremely scared um to move in with
her and just to leave everything I know
everything I'm comfortable with and I
just was curious to know what you could
share just how do I how do I cope with
this anxiety and just whether or not it
would be a good idea for us in the long
run to make the choice to move in with
her temporarily to pay off its Deb sure
so
um whenever somebody tells me they're
anxious my first thought is good good
for
you your body's working great to protect
you from something or from several
things and embedded in your answer I
think might be one of the the
solutions sounds like you grew up in a
chaotic mess and you're
grandmother was your Lifeline Fair yes
100% And then you got a
job and then you got
married then you got your own
place and your body felt an experienced
something it has never felt
before which was
peace and then this opportunity shows up
that I kind of want to be honest no I
want to be totally honest kind of sounds
like it's a benefit to you and your
wife and it's kind of a benefit to your
grandmother and it wouldn't surprise me
that the woman who saved
you also needed you to be okay because
she had some guilt about what her kids
had
done and so in the same on one hand God
you're so blessed and and lucky to have
a grandmother that came for
you and you've been a Xanax for
her you made sure she was going to be
all right Fair yes sir
okay sounds to me like your body's
working real real
well now the question you have to decide
is
25,000 bucks left that means at
Christmas 2024 y'all are going to owe
nobody anything if y'all stay on this
current
trajectory 12 months from now yes
sir one year how old are you I'm 28 okay
when you're 40 you don't even remember
this
year or you work crazy over the summer
and earn another X couple thousand bucks
do an X Y and Z and you move this thing
up to September of next
year that's one thing you look at your
wife and you say you know what we're
building our own life our own home great
we're just going to keep knocking it out
and you know what that path is going to
be
hard but y'all proven to yourselves you
can do it or sell sell everything leave
your rent house move in with Grandma
both the good and the
bad
and accelerate this debt payoff when are
you going to be done if you moved in
with your
grandma we we would uh we looked at the
debt calculator and it said June
okay so it sounds like it'll knock about
three or four months
off is that about right yes sir
okay is that worth
it
I would think so um just because my wife
and I are so ready to move on from this
step we've been you know struggling with
it I mean not as long as others you know
praise the Lord but nonetheless it's it
it does have it does have a a strain on
our marriage that we're not able to move
Beyond uh this and move into the next
you know baby step or phase of our life
but make it make it make it I mean be
super clear it's going to be a strand on
your marriage moving with your grandma
yes and it's going to be a strand on
your marriage if you both decide to get
um start driving Uber after you get done
teaching school and you do that until 10
o'clock and you all get this thing done
by June on your
own which is
possible
yes I've got to a place in my life where
and I should have said this earlier it's
going to be hard to stay the course in
your rent house it's also going to be
hard to move in with your
grandma you got some demons there right
I do yeah and that doesn't mean she's
not amazing that doesn't mean she didn't
save your life that doesn't mean any of
those things all that can be true at the
same
time but that's going to be hard also so
the path forward
is what's harder you going to
choose and anytime I'm faced with that
that decision
I want to choose the hard path that is
going to give me two things the most
freedom and
autonomy and the most strength on the
other
side and the way you've lined it out for
me if you guys stay where you are and
choose to double down on working even
more than you already
work and you decide I want this thing
done by July July 1
and I see a path forward if I earn this
much extra money delivering pizzas or
doing whatever working the night shift
I'm working from 8:00 p.m. to 11: p.m.
throwing boxes or 600 P p.m. to midnight
throwing boxes and then I teach the next
day
whatever on the back end of
that you're free you don't live with
somebody you don't have to have the hard
conversation about well it's time to
move out well are you sure you got to
move out because my feet hurt and I
really need your help on you avoid all
that and if you need to take a weekend
off from working three jobs or four jobs
while you're also teaching you can but
you can't take a weekend off from
Grandma's
house so that path is free and on the
back end you know you and your wife
know after a lifetime of chaos a life
timee of trying to figure out how to
stand up on your own two feet and stare
down some of these demons
you're going to hold her hand and know
nothing can knock y'all
down yeah and it's it's just uh
extremely tough just because I've um
never been a decisive individual and
it's really hard always been hard for me
to choose and here's what's cool hold on
here's what's cool there is no wrong
answer here there's only two hard
paths that's
it if you choose Ethan like you know
what we're staying the course I'm
staying here honey I'm going to work
like
crazy and by the way you're going to
miss me in the evenings when I'm working
this second job but if I move in with we
move in with Grandma you're going to
miss me because I'm going to be up
having tea or coffee or whatever with
Grandma and you're going to wish that we
were our sex life was better and we were
spending time watching TV you're going
to wish that if we lived at Grandma's
house cuz we're not going to be rocking
till the wheels fall off at Grandma's
house
right right I just made this podcast
weird for everybody I realize that
but if you get three months down the
road and your body just starts falling
apart on you I just can't work until
midnight and get up at 6:00 a.m. and go
be a teacher all day which by the way I
think you
can then you move with
Grandma but you will have blown your
whole life apart you'll have got rid of
your home you'll have got rid of your
furniture you got rid of your stuff and
you move in with Grandma for three
months and realize this isn't working
out there's it's going to be a much more
difficult path to
untangle and by the way this idea of
decisiveness it's been uncomfortable for
you to stand on two feet it's my guess
growing up when you made a decision you
got hit in the mouth for it or the
adults in your life took your decisions
and flushed them down the toilet and so
your body has learned over time don't
make a decision because you just
complicate things for everybody when you
do the path out of that is a whole bunch
of little winds if you can't do a
pull-up
cool get on a chair and climb all the
way up until you're in pull-up
position and just five times a day just
slow as you can release yourself
down then get up and do it again and
then get up and do it again what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
pullup and we're going to pull it apart
into a bunch of little pieces and we're
going to do those little pieces until
one day I can pull myself up one time
and I'm going to scream and cheer that I
got one pullup
in then I'm going to keep
going and suddenly after six months a
year you could do 10 at a time you can
do 20 at a time without
stopping that's how you build strength
the path out of this anxiousness
feeling the nerd word is exposure I'm
going to slowly head into the storm so
my body says hey you don't make
decisions I'm making this
one and lucky for me there's not a wrong
answer hey hey hey you can't work two
jobs I'm gonna give it a shot you
watch you're going to be in debt forever
you watch I'm cutting this time in half
the calculator says uh 10 months cool
I'm going to do it in six what has to be
true for me and my wife and our work
schedules for us to be done in six I'm
going to build it that way and then on
the back end you're going to have taught
your body n you can make decisions
you're going to have taught your body D
you can work crazy hours for a short
season to accomplish a goal you're going
to have taught your
wife that guy's way stronger than I
thought he was you're going to have
taught you that you're way stronger than
you
were personally I like that
path there is a season to sell your
house and move in with your mom move in
with your grandma I get that but just
from this little conversation my
recommendation if you were my brother or
you my friend I would say hey get Gnarly
and stay the course and on the back end
you'll have
freedom and you're going to be stronger
than you ever thought
imaginable hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life for you and your wife
to
read start looking at that the whole six
daily choices chart and y'all start
following that thing
religiously Little Steps man you got
this holler at me when you pay all your
debts off we'll celebrate
you